all right so we have saurabh saying that
he wants to do data development using
Python and understanding neural networks
for performing machine learning
that's pretty cool
um I'm curious to know about rest of the
participants as well why do you wish to
Learn Python is it just for uh as since
the field is pretty interesting or
are you working on some kind of research
work is that the reason why you wish to
do python
or is it part of your curriculum as a
part of your
um let's say undergraduate degree or
your master's degree
so for those participants who have just
joined I was just chatting up with rest
of the participants to know about their
educational background such as is it
computer science or life science
background and I was also asking why do
you wish to Learn Python
so let me know in the chat as well
for those participants who have just
joined
right so we have one participant uh Sulu
is saying that I'm currently a PhD
student in neuropharmacology I am
interested in drug Discovery and Drug
repurposing and I just finished the
omixologic introduction to events
addicts so uh what is your current
knowledge of python uh do you consider
yourself a beginner
or
uh medium or is it advanced
how would you rate your personal skills
invite them
all right and nitish Kumar says he's a
beginner in Python uh could you please
also let me know what is your
educational background
are you from computer science or are you
from a life science background
all right so I can see that a lot of the
participants are from a life science
background
um and uh please let me know in the chat
and with that I like to start today's
webinar so hello everyone a very long
greeting to one and all my name is Sri
gavi Krishna Kumar and I would like to
welcome you all for today's webinar on
biomedical data science in Python this
program will cover practical and
conceptual aspects of machine learning
and application to high throughput
biomedical data using various tools and
python throughout the program students
will get an understanding of the
opportunities and limitations of machine
learning in the context of pre-clinical
and clinical research
and the program is designed as a
combination of online resources
practical assignments and live workshops
that will be conducted online and in
today's webinar we will first sign up on
the almost logic learn portal and learn
how to navigate through the various
courses that are associated with today's
yes
uh I guess your screen is not moving
uh yes it's the first uh biomedical data
science slide
uh let's check it's not full screen yeah
is it moving now
is it more it's it's moving but it's not
full screen could you please see if it's
let me just reshare my screen yes yes
thank you
so how about now
uh is it still Elizabeth
yeah it's now fine
okay thank you and in today's webinar we
will first sign up on the only strategic
learn portal and learn how to navigate
the various courses associated with
python followed by this we will have a
Hands-On session by the program mentor
and finally the participants will be
introduced to the registration process
and program costs so before we begin
with today's webinar let me also take a
brief moment to introduce you to the
team behind the program we are a
us-based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
Commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omics logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
and students will also have access to
the omic Strategic resources but how
does it help Advance bioinformatics
teaching omics logic is a portal for
practical and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy permit and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omic's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
and this also comes with an access to
the example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research
and users will also be given directions
to access the T by info platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data and the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
bioinformatic pipelines and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multi-amix
platform
another important resource that you will
get as a part of the program is access
to the omics logic code playground which
will help you develop coding skills
while learning popular packages in
Python to visualize annotate and analyze
complex patterns in biological data in
addition you will also get access to the
Google collab mobiles as a part of the
training program
and with so much data available on any
biological topic and question completing
a program seems like a great opportunity
but it can be challenging and that is
why you also have the opportunity to
seek Mentor guidance and learn alongside
an International Community of
bioinformatics and data science
enthusiasts now as a part of the
biomedical data science in Python
program you will be mainly going through
three major coursework which includes
getting started with bioinformatics this
is suitable for those participants who
do not have a previous background in
Python and here in this course you will
be learning data visualization creating
DNA DNA replication and reverse
complements using python and once you
have finished gaining a basic knowledge
of python you can next advance to data
science courses and to learn logical
aspects of data science one can refer to
the machine learning for biomedical data
course which will teach you about the
statistical methods where unsupervised
and unsupervised machine learning
methods will be used for analyzing
biomedical data followed by this we will
be going one step further and learning
more in depth about the data science
using Python and here are elements of
data science such as data wrangling
visualization statistical analysis and
machine learning will be taught much
more in depth using python
and so now to view the various courses
and example projects on the omixological
and portal you need to first sign up on
the portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the learn portal
these are the features that you need to
update on your account which includes a
profile image full name with appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handles
a brief buyer about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and research interests and the mentors
can view your activity under the
activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will show up under
the courses Tab and finally once you
complete the courses the certificates
will appear under the certificates that
and so now with that let us Begin by
signing up on the omics logic learn
portal
I am sharing the link to the learn
portal in the chat box
all right so for now those participants
who do not have a previous account on
the portal let me show you how you can
sign up so you can simply click on the
tab this is create an account option
that you see here and here you can
simply enter your name email ID and give
a password or you also have the option
to log in using any of your social media
handles uh so this could be your Google
Facebook Apple account GitHub account or
even Twitter
and for those participants who already
have an account on the portal you can
simply click on login now option and
sign in and so with that I would like to
pause for a couple of seconds so that
the participants can sign up on the
portal
so once you have done sign up on the
portal please put a yes in the chat box
and if you already have an account on
the portal please put it done in the
chat box so that I can get a fair idea
about the participants
I'll pause for a couple of seconds I'm
monitoring the chat
all right monalysis is done
uh please make sure to sign up on the
portal so that uh along with today's
webinar the program enter will be
showing you the various resources that
you will be getting as a part of the
program and to take a look at it it will
be important that you have a account on
the portal all right so we do have few
done
in the chat box
all right I'm waiting for the 45 plus
participants to
uh let me know
all right so I do have couple of uh yes
in the chat box so I'm going to sign in
on the portal since I already have an
account on the portal but along the way
if you're having any queries please put
them in the chat box
so once you sign up on the portal uh
this is the main page that you will be
seeing so here when you scroll down uh
you'll see a search bar that's asked for
looking for a specific course so here
you can simply enter the keyword that
you're looking for so for instance if
you are interested look for python
courses simply enter the keyword Python
and that will show up the various
courses and example projects that makes
use of the Python so here is the first
pose that I was talking about where for
those participants who are new to the
field of uh python then you can get
started with this course sharing the
link in the chat box so that
participants can take a look at it and
this uh course the python 2 course is
much more advanced and these four
participants who already have a prior
knowledge of python
so you can
go through it and
have a look at various courses and
example projects that are there so now
going to the uh part where you need to
update your profile for this you need to
click on the tab that says welcome back
with your email ID
so once you click here you'll see an
icon that is profile so once you click
on this you will be able to update your
profile image you can put your full name
make sure that it is in proper
capitalization add a buy about yourself
here I've added my education background
and my research interest and finally you
can link your social media handles as
well so in my case I've linked my
LinkedIn account and my arcade all right
and so with that
um I'd like to pause for a couple of
seconds if the participants have any
queries please let me know
foreign
so with that now I'd like to pass on the
stage to today the program Mentor Dr
raghavendra Lakshmi Narayan could be
explaining much more about the program
details so over to you sir
thank you very much uh yeah and let me
set up my screen share and continue
can you see my screen
yes sir this is a program page that you
will get in get more information in this
program page later so uh before
proceeding so let's let's ask how many
of you have some prior experience in
coding or in Python generally
or our Kodi is also good
um you can start recording your
responses to me in the chat I'm
following the chat if you are an
absolute newbie to coding or to python
you can start by entering 0 1 or
something then if you are decent enough
in in Python to uh take some very basic
calculations and yeah make some very
basic calculations that is five if you
are expert like or moderately expert
like taking codes from elsewhere like
stack Overflow or other pipelines and
then modify that for you then you can
enter seven or a depending upon your
expertise right and
okay so I see a lot of entries at zero
so welcome to New World of python I can
say that and some entries that people
who have some exposure to python
generally so I believe those who have
entered five and Clement very nice to
see you and uh people who have entered
five knows how to install python in your
computer
right so that's good so we need we need
to do that at some point of time
for your own data analysis also for
reproducibility of some of the analysis
I will show you how we are going to go
over some of the resources in this uh in
this program right as we go along so
let's let's deal let's start with
absolute basics of what what to do if if
you are if you are an absolute newbie in
Python right so um SRI Gary actually
went through this little bit so let me
go over this one more time so we have a
python introduction course one so you go
to omix logic courses and I think that
there are a couple of uh yes there is
python introduction course one so I'm
copying the the link from there and then
placing it in my starting
okay let's go over this one
and this is this is for
people who wants to get started with
python so this this starts with uh how
to introduce or how to install python in
your place and Etc right and it stops it
for example what python can actually
offer it right so it gives you a good
confidence booster or how to use Python
for some basic calculations right and
all of these data sets that we are going
to deal with is going to be biologically
related
okay so if you go to the first lesson
the first lesson aim is to help you
understand how to load data into a
Python's environment which we will also
see but before that there are multiple
ways of acquiring python to your
computer so which you should know so
this is what we will be uh covering in
this in this lesson right so for example
python can be installed and then you can
use Python for your analysis in an
interactive development environment like
vs code or something like anaconda or
something like
um Associated resources like you can use
set up your browser to access python in
a jupyter notebook kind of environment
right that is obviously what you see
here but we can also make use of online
uh resources like Google collaboratory
notebook that will actually help you to
develop or help you to develop your code
in a an environment that can be had with
your peers shared with us mentors and
shared with others so that um
assignments can be completed and we can
check them so most of this courses and
the sessions and sessions involved will
have two forms of interacting with
python right one is interacting with
python from the learn omicslogic.com
portal itself so let's go over that
first so in this portal the aim is going
to be extremely simple right all the
code related lessons will start with an
introduction or with the aim of how to
perform this analysis right in this
specific lesson the aim is to make you
familiarize with python so the
introduction starts from installing
Python and then following that we will
have sections of learn the code and try
it yourself learn the code and try it
yourself blocks where first in the learn
the code section
we give information on the core as code
blocks given and in Black environment
and color coded by Python's syntax color
coding followed by uh what happens or
what is different constituents or parts
of this specific code right and we
explain the each and every nuts and
bolts of this code in this code blocks
right so if this particular code is in
is is going to involve importing some of
the packages and modules into Python's
environment then we describe that so
what does the keyword import do and what
does pandas mean and what why do you
have to give it a name so we we deal
with that and then following this this
everybody has to learn at some point of
time the way the objects and the way in
which python is actually going to
interact with your data right we will go
over this extensively when we when we
are going to discuss our first session
but to give you a small overview
you can load the data numerical data or
tabular numerical data as metrics or you
can load for example a data that
consists of some columns which are
character oriented some columns which
are numerical oriented and some other
columns can be for example logical
oriented right
they can be excuse me
Audible
sorry about that yeah so uh
so how python is going to interpret with
your data so let's say that we are going
to take a typical data or mixed data
that that will have for example one or
two columns of character uh columns and
then the rest of this is going to be
numerical oriented some of your columns
could be logical like uh true or false
right so data frame is one of the object
which will which is going to suit
loading your data into uh this kind of
an object which will data frame will
accommodate
um Columns of different data types into
one environment which is not possible in
a matrix or in which is not possible in
an array
as Matrix and arrays are actually
reserved for data types or data of
uniform data types so most of the time
or all of the town all the time we are
going to load omics data type into a
data frame and then comes how to access
elements of the data frame so that we
will also discuss so in this lesson this
lesson is going to deal with only 1A how
to load your file into a Python's
environment and how to
view it or how to display so you have
different ways of doing that or
different
um
syntaxes of doing that you can use or
you can uh not different syntaxes you
can use a different for example
functions to input and load different
file formats you can load file formats
that is of the file that is of the
format text and in that sense in that
case you have to mention where is my
file and then you have to describe some
characteristics of my file right for
this function to be able to interpret
your files right what are the
characteristics absolutely necessary
characteristics that I have to describe
like how two columns are separated so in
this case this separation can be a tab
oriented separation or tab delimited
separation or it can be comma Del meter
separation like comma here CSV right we
can use both or we can also use any
other special characters sometimes in
the omics data comma is often used for
the description of the header or some
other
uh some other users in that case
semicolon is often used so you can also
use a semicolon here depending upon what
your data is right and one more
description of the data like whether do
I have column names for my data or not
so these are all absolutely necessary
but the but without the location of the
file the rest of the things will not
work right but even without the rest of
the description then this will work by
assuming
the default values that this function is
going to assume so that we will you can
check it out by taking it out and trying
to load this data right where can you
practice that so once you have gone
through how to load files into into
python for example we can use read
underscore Excel function we can use
read underscore CSV function and we can
use read underscore table function and
what are the difference between those
and how can you make use of that
and we can use for the different data
types of my data frame using df.d types
function we will also
go over in a more tactical oriented uh
fashion when we are going to uh go
through the sessions but here I'm going
I'm giving you an overview of how you
will interact with python resources from
uh learn portal right so once you have
gone through this code and the
background of the code and what
different constituents of the code
actually giving you you can try your
knowledge in this area right in this
practice area so if you have access to
this portal please open this up
and we can practice together right if we
have time we I think we will have time
for performing one more practice where
we are going to produce some pictures
but for that I want all of you to uh be
comfortable with this particular lesson
I think thank you srigori you have
pasted the necessary uh
link
is everybody here can you did you open
this particular page those who have
access to this page
and this page is by the way or this
lesson is by the way left free most of
the most of the first lesson of any of
the any of the courses the courses are
left free uh yes great so if you have an
account you can easily open this
okay great so go to this try to yourself
practice section
so what what happens here right uh I'll
display or I'll show you how this works
so you can for example go home and try
it out or if you are
quick enough on following here you can
also try it out here so I completely
understood what is in the learn the code
section like how to import the packages
there are only three sections there will
be three parts in this in this
particular learn the code area how to
import the packages right come down
and how to import files
and
for example yeah view the files as some
data types right most likely how to
import and View files in Python so let's
let's go here so the first challenge is
import the necessary packages in in this
one so one one small background tidbit
about this particular page this page
loads python in your computer
right loads python from chrome in your
computer and it is designed to work very
well with chrome if you have latest
Chrome please use it if you face some
problems please let us know we will know
how to deal with those problems later
right okay so what do we have here
there's a python console loaded and
there is an option for running and
there's an option for drop file but we
don't have any files here this is about
importing packages and in this practice
section we have deleted or we have left
some of the code incomplete so that you
can complete that code and complete your
understanding so for example if you run
this code as it is let's see what it
does
it's going to load Python and it's going
to run this code in this console
try running this code
it is
it will take a while because it's going
to load up these libraries
I hope it's it's been working
did it did it reply anything for any of
you
it is still kind of struggling to open
for me did it work for anyone of you
no okay you're still facing the same
issues
okay I think uh there is some issue with
this particular page to load okay let's
let's let's worry about that so let's
come down one more so what do we have
here uh we can actually load this one
and uh
um and complete this I think um let's
complete this in syntax I just want to
show you how wrong syntaxes work
here and let's try one more time by
pressing import ah now it actually works
if you don't see the spinning square
button then it says it it means that it
is not loading so what did I do I just
pressed this or you can press refresh
and start start running this particular
code so it's going to take a while to
run it's basically importing these
packages or loading these packages so we
wait for this to load the packages
yes so now it is Success so I see that I
have a success running the code but
sometimes the answer is incorrect that
should not be the case here but it's
okay the success is I get success
running the code I get answering correct
because this particular code block is
not associated with any answer okay so
let's move on I want to load this file
into Python's environment and then to
display so what do we do
um it says I can right click on this
link and save the file in my system and
drop the file here so that the pipe so
that python can access this file right
so let's do that first right click here
and save link as
okay save you can save here
and save to downloads where I can access
this from
okay and then I have to drop the file
here
let's go
okay
here is my phone
okay my downloads are here and this is
the file that I want to drop
you see the file is dropped here with
the same name don't change the name so
that the name is uh the python can
recognize us so if you run it as it is
let's pause it again and run it one more
time
it's going to create an error because
there is none of the packages loaded so
we need a python package in pandas to
load here so we know the command for by
importing pandas package so you can copy
it from here or you can write it
important as
that's pretty because PD is what is
mentioned here so that is done okay I
clear this and then run it again
okay this is again fighting me
okay did any one of you get it running
suddenly it started it has to give a
report an error so but unfortunately
it's not doing that if if the code is
wrong so there is something changed okay
let's complete it so what happens here
it's there is some issue with this one
like the separator is not mentioned so
let's mention the separator
and then uh
okay let's do this
yes
so now I get success in running the code
the answer is correct we
as a we in the background or in the back
end do not have a lot of freedom in how
python is going to interpret or how
python is going to
um yeah
interpret with your codes so something
has changed in how python is going to
deal with your syntax errors in this
code if there is a syntax error it looks
like python is not at all going to run
type okay let's do this without any
syntax error so I don't want in in
include any syntax error so what happens
if I don't uh give the intended output
that's what I want to show you so if I
clear the pack clear the console and
then run I get this particular output I
want you to notice what this output is
right this particular feedback success
in running the code but the answer is
incorrect so what does it mean that
means in my the code that I have
uh included or
that I have written in the code block is
without any syntax errors and is
perfectly fine but the intended output
is not being met so what is the intended
output import and view the text file so
let's view the text file here this this
will also work for example
if you change something here oh yeah
let's run this
then
now I get success in running the code
and answer is correct so if you are
successful in until this point
let me know we will amp up amp this up a
little bit
and I will show you how to do some
preliminary exploratory data analysis
using python for automix data
so
are you successful in following me in
interacting with python using the learn
portals code
areas not running then you might have
some syntax error in your uh this one
don't worry if it's not running because
we will have plenty of time to learn why
it is not running and how to fix it
during our sessions but I am here to
demonstrate you that you have a medium
in the learn portal where you can learn
the code and then complete the complete
learning The Code by testing yourself
against
these challenges that we have devised
for you in testing the code section okay
yeah okay so somebody asked me to please
wait so while we wait I want you to go
to uh the python lesson two
right if you go to for example go to
courses in omics logic okay
and it's going to open up everything and
then inside this courses we have these
tags right bioinfo in Python right if
you go to bioinfo in Python
the answer is incorrect so perfect so
that means you might have most likely
not fulfilled the separator correctly so
that that's one of the reason why it is
actually giving you answer is incorrect
so here you go to python course 2 right
let's go to python course two
and I'm copying and pasting this
particular link for you to access so
inside this python course too so we have
left this data wrangling and
visualization lesson two uh open to view
and open to try it out for all of you
for 24 hours so let's go into this data
wrangling and visualization and see what
we can use Python's tool for visualize a
visualization of some of the omics data
analysis right omex data inputs so you
have to go through this introduction
which tells you what can be achieved by
performing some exploratory data
analysis which is going to give you an
overall understanding of what my data
constitutes right it can involve for
example creating some concise tables
like how many male samples do I have in
my list how many female samples do I
have in our list right how many samples
for biology magical condition one how
many samples for biological condition
two
right so those things that we can
definitely
so and what do we how do we load for
example anomics data analomics data into
a Python's environment
follow along this is exactly the same
syntax nothing has changed here in the
first two lines right
only except the uh
the link for where to find link for
where to find the input is except for
that nothing has changed in this
particular line okay
okay so and and what else does it do
let's click on this download full table
here and see what this table actually
gives us uh
looks like right save link cash again
okay we can save link here
and go to my find it again so we will
use it somewhere else right and open it
uh using Excel or numbers whichever you
have access to
let's forget about this
it looks like it's a big file
okay success so just like this this is
this is uh transcriptomics data where we
have uh transcript IDs in the First
Column and there expression levels
Quantified for different sample types in
along the given along the columns right
these are all transcript IDs for uh
along the rows and we have samples along
the columns so this is the expression
quantification of this particular
transcript for this particular sample
okay enough of this kind of introduction
we will deal with this more in the
sessions so how to for example
use some of the uh
visualization option to visualize some
patterns in this data right we can use
heat map right we can come down and then
use a box plot
box plot and bar plot so all these
options are available so if you are
still along with me come to the for
example the second practice it yourself
section right not the first one second
practice if your subsection you come
down scroll all the way down you get it
here
so practice the core
so here again we have to load these
packages let's let's see that we have
loaded this and
um
this particular
this particular section deals with
finding for example the dimensions of
the data so that's what we can do here
and let's see where we have to make some
box plot or something we don't yeah here
okay we have a box plot for this here so
let's try to get a box plot done for
this right so we need obviously to
load the data into gene expression right
so let's see
gene expression
as will be
PD dot read underscore table and what is
that table name is going to be for
example what is the table name that we
have here
final cell with this one okay
exactly the same thing txt and
separator equals this one and then
header
zero
zero oh right and then we give this uh I
think we have to use dot dot blocks or
box plot
box plot let's check we can check also
here
in the learn the code section and plot
dot box yes and
wrong and using box Dot Plot
so let's use that wherever we
and we were here
laptop box
Okay so
okay so we have this one that's good and
uh title equals this let's see this one
works we need to of course import uh
pandas here
import
and as a speedy
and let's see if this one works and this
should work okay
this won't work because I have forgot to
drop the file so it's going to throw me
an error and let's stop the file before
it throws me an error so
okay it's it's running the code okay
plot dot show box plot is good so what
do we have
let's run one more time let's see okay
[Music]
there is some sort of error somewhere
gene expression dot dot box
I think you should do a lot
okay great
it's a great start
yeah let's
let's go back and learn our code let's
do this again
so what did I miss
okay this is correct and this is also
correct and plotted box is also correct
but it's not showing up uh
gene expression is not showing up for
some reasons
okay
[Music]
okay let's check that why it is not
showing up but yeah this is this is how
we interact with this one I thought it's
it's going to work in this case for some
reasons you can just put table
let's take it out
let's leave it at default values
okay
it doesn't have to go this way
what does it say
okay python is not loaded let's see
yeah I think
I think it's not loading the libraries
that's one of the reason it's it should
it's your developer let's see new
develop a tools
sometimes the python fails too low and
if that if it fails to load
okay looks like sometimes a python is
fails to load then you have to go to
view developer tools and do this okay
for this reason we also have another way
of interacting with the course as given
here which is going to be most suitable
way of interacting with the code for us
like
accessing these codes from a Google
collaboratory notebook so
why is this not good let's
let's refresh this maybe then it will
work
waiting for this to refresh
okay let's kill this
okay let's do this one more time uh by
going to course number two
or we can do the visualization here but
what I wanted to tell you is you can use
the visualization option here to
visualize for example practice report
here or you can in the end of this we
give access to uh collaboratory notebook
which is going to be our
um yeah all the past classes has been
from collab yes I know that but we don't
want to go to collab right at the
beginning Clement so that's why we will
start with uh letting you interact with
python in this case with python it's
always tricky because python loads in
your local computer as I mentioned
sometimes this process is prone to this
is processes error Pro and it may may
load or may not load in my computer so
that's why we have the alternative
version of accessing or uh in
of interacting with python with Google
collaboratory notebook so in Google
collab for example as given in this
particular lesson so which is uh what I
want to show you in another case right
how are we going to give you links to
collab and you can get access or answers
from that using where python is used in
in some of the example example projects
or example of projects most often or
more often than not python is going to
be used in many of the downstream
analysis so if you click again bioinfo
in Python and we have these projects
project links
so this is a course and come down we
have a project here this is another
course we have a project here so if you
click on this project
this project will this is an example
project where we show you how to take
data from existing publication or
publicly available resources and answer
the specific research question so in
that research question might require
some of the analysis to be completed
using python so we can use Python to for
example take or understand the
heterogeneity in single cell data of
this breast cancer so here for example
we give you what is the input file that
we are going to access and then how to
perform this analysis and what is the
output that you are going to uh
now visualize when you perform this
analysis right in the end you come down
you come to the annotated vessels and uh
sorry
here you will have a link for
Google collaboratory notebook
in the assignment section yeah here
let's see here if it is here okay uh
you for example we can start with the
Google collaboratory notebook here and
then
using collab.2 option
that's going to open up a Google
collaborate notebook we will get an
introduction to what a Google collab is
and how to use this for our area for our
analysis but mostly if you want to use
Python's courses for Google collab you
can just copy this course and then paste
it in this crash pad on this Google
collab and then we will run this
analysis so that is going to be the
default mode of instruction uh in which
you and I are going to interact during
the sessions so I'm going to open up one
collaboratory notebook for one session
and then take the codes from the lesson
and execute it along with you in the
collabs in the Google collabs and then
we will compare our results and we will
compare our
journey through learning python for
bioinformatics data analysis and you
will also learn necessary uh
you'll also learn necessary background
for performing this analysis for example
many of the background might involve
machine learning analysis or some uh
structuring of the omics data analysis
for different types of comics data so
all of this will get will get you will
get introduction to and also you will
get necessary resources to try it out so
that's why you will actually start
understanding how the data is and and
what can we
do or what can what kind of analysis
that we can perform for that data to
understand the trends and to use uh
Python's uh
excellent libraries to perform some
Advanced statistical analysis to uh
relate those Trends to the phenotypical
conditions or different biological state
of the samples so I know some of the
Python demonstration did not go through
this is an ongoing problem because
python loads in your computer sometimes
it loads sometimes it does not so that's
why we have a collaboratory session
involved for each and every one of the
session in this program so if you have
any queries related to how are we going
to interact with python and what is what
promises does these courses offer you
please let me know in the chat box we
will get uh get on with it and if if you
don't have any questions that's fine and
I look forward to meet many of you
during the course of this program and I
want to pass this on to Sri gauri or
Spurs yes I'll be taking up now
oh we do have a query in the chat from
kajal so can you give some topics of
research for doing PhD in biomedical
using machine learning techniques that's
a separate session it's a project right
that's a separate session itself right
you can for example uh I'll give you
I'll give you pointers where to go we
have a course on how to design a
bioinformatics project in learnport
so please go through that course that
course is going to show you how you can
effectively start figuring out a
question that is going to impress or
address your interest or that is going
to address for example a general public
interest and that is going to make use
of some of the resources that we have
um
yeah that we have uh from publicly
available sources so course number nine
how to design a bioinformatics project
is where you should go to uh for example
Identify some key topics for doing uh
bioinformatics research okay
all right so thank you so much
um is my screen visible
hello
uh is my screen visible
ES3 you can see your screen
thank you so much so uh so far we
covered the basic uh topics that will be
covered for a participant who is new to
the python and once you get uh used to
the various topics that are covered in
Python and you apply the knowledge that
you have gained so far on example
projects you can also take one step
further and carry out your own
independent research projects so now
let's take a look at some of the
research projects that these students
have carried out using python so here we
have a cohort of students from
Georgetown University who had carried
out a diverse range of research projects
on topics ranging from infectious
diseases metabolic disorders
Neuroscience psychiatric disorders and
so on for example Rohan Harris he is
using python to identify different
expression of genes and asymptomatic and
symptomatic covid-19 patients by Genta
and then we also have Rima who's
carrying out her project on metabolic
disorders where she's trying to build
machine learning models for accurate
prediction of whether the individual has
diabetes or not and then we have Jordan
Henry who is uh carrying out a
predictive model for post chemotherapy
neurodegeneration Based on rnec data and
then we also have an ongoing project by
Michelle beat who's carrying out gene
expression changes in at-risk and
diagnosed PTSD patients to identify
potential treatments so all of these are
some of the ongoing python projects
projects that are there I would also
like to show some of the completed
projects that are there on the portal so
for example
um Simpson has carried out a independent
research project on brain tumor subtype
exploration for candidate biomarkers I'm
sharing the link in the chat boxes
project that participants can take a
look at and go through
and then we also have yunju who has
carried out unsupervised clustering and
multiple classes of opioid use using
python I'm sharing the link to her
research project as well
and then we have a PhD student who
carried out an independent research
project on random forest classifier for
back curious and classification so all
of these are some of the various
research projects that have been carried
out using python so where can you find
more of such projects on the portal that
let me take you to the portal once again
and show you so here when you
um go to the courses tab next to it
you'll also see a tab that says projects
so once you click on this
it will show you the various projects
that other students have done and this
could be in various Fields such as
oncology infectious diseases as I
described so the participants can take a
look at the various projects that the
students have carried out in this link
and uh with that I'd like to pass on the
stage to sonalika for those participants
who are interested to enroll for the
program so the state disorders
thank you so much SRI gauri and a very
warm good morning or good evening to all
of you present here
now I would like to show you all how you
can register yourself for the program
biomedical data science in Python so
here is the link to the program page
that you need to visit to to register
yourself for the program
it's in the chat box now once you're on
the program page if you scroll down you
can first of all find the schedule of
the program which tells how many
interactive sessions we are going to
have you have the lender with the dates
are marked also you have all the
information here presented here for all
the topics that would be covered and the
coding lessons that you have to go
through as a part of each and every
session now these coding lessons are
such lessons that Dr raghav took you
through from the python coursework that
you have to follow along which has got
the concepts the logic the syntax and
the practice sessions you have to submit
your assignments and complete the
quizzes in these coding lessons so one
session will involve one minute guided
live session that you will have and you
need to complete these coding lessons as
well now the question that was raised uh
in the chat regarding not being
available during the duration of the
program so I want to mention that for
such people who are not available at the
time of the live session let's say or at
the duration of the program they can
follow the program asynchronously that
means you can go along the session
recording the session recording the
mentor session recording would be
uploaded on the program page itself when
the session is completed to give you an
example I'll take you to another ongoing
program so once the session is completed
we put the recording of the session on
the program page itself once you enroll
you'll be a part of the program page
where you can watch the recording and go
through the resources once you complete
the session you click on complete
session button and you are good to go or
proceed ahead all right so for those who
are not available
uh at the time of the live session you
can watch the recording you can watch
the recording and take your questions
um via email or we are also going to
form a Skype chat group we'll have a
Skype chat group set up for all the
participants in the program you can ask
your question in that group from the
mentor if Skype chat is not suitable we
can also have a WhatsApp group where you
can ask your questions and be glad to
assist you we'll also have some live q a
sessions in between so maybe you can try
joining those sessions all right so that
was all about schedule and how you can
manage attending the sessions or going
through the recordings now when you
scroll down you will find all the
details of each and every session on
which days they are scheduled they are
generally scheduled on Tuesdays and
Fridays of the month of uh in the month
of January and you have the topics that
we'll cover and also the coding lessons
are mentioned here that will be
following around
the program has got 14 sessions two
sessions every week and we'll be closing
the program on March 10th so that was
about the schedule now how do you
register yourself so when you scroll
down you can see three different types
of subscription levels that you can pick
to enroll yourself in the program one is
45 days another one is 60 days and then
you have the 90 days of the program
duration
now here the different slides in how you
can proceed from completing the training
program to completing a research project
so in the 45 days you'll get the access
to all the mentor guided live sessions
and then you will also uh go through
each one of these resources that are
mentioned on the program page that I
showed up and then on in the 60 days of
the subscription level you will get
one-on-one mental support to prepare a
research proposal that you can further
work uh as a research project that could
be published and in the 90 days of the
subscription level you will be able to
complete a research project and have it
published so the difference in these
three diff different subscription levels
just lies in the time period I'll say or
the duration you get extra time period
to work on a research project or a
research question applying the skill set
that if you learn or gain from the
specific training program
now uh the pricing here is mentioned in
dollars if you are not from us but a
different country
you can scroll up and change the
pricing let's say I'm in India right now
so the currency would be INR I can
change the currency to INR and then it
would be easy for me to understand what
the pricing looks like right now we are
offering some good scholarships uh so
those who are interested to enroll in
the program can reach out to us on
marketing either atomicslogic.com so
that we can share the coupon code with
you applying which you will get a good
scholarship on the program
has shared the uh scholarship code
already in the program which is python
50 which will give you a 50 scholarship
uh you can save it with you and then
proceed with your enrollment
all right so that was it that I wanted
to mention if there are any further
questions or doubts you can ask in the
chat box or you can also unmute yourself
and ask and we'll be glad to assist you
so we have a query in the chat from
Matthew how long does the early birdover
last
I think the offer lasts for five more
days it's the or till 25th shubham can
you please confirm in the chat box how
long does the offer last what is the
coupon code
availability
yes it's up till the yes thank you
shubham it is valid till December 25th
if you talk about the placement
assistance I would like to share this
a section with all of you here
on the omics logic learn portal itself
if you scroll down the post bottom part
of the site you'll see job listing here
we list out specific jobs which requires
the skill sets that a portal offers all
right so once you complete a program you
can find a suitable job based on the
specific cell the specific skill set
that you have gained in the program and
apply
yes it would be available for 45 days or
if you pick up the first subscription
level that is for 45 days
Shri gauri has also shared the link in
the chat box for job listings and I
think it would be helpful to all of you
not just Matthew
and uh we have one query from Dr Avinash
how long uh the course materials are
accessible
so it depends on the subscription type
you pick if it's 45 days of subscription
type then you'll get the access for 45
days if it is 60 or 90 so it will matter
on the number of days you pick
or you wish to enroll in the program
uh his query is after opening the
subscription
how long the course materials are
accessible
yes so if the person takes up the
subscription for uh for let's say 45
days it will be activated for 45 days or
accessible for 45 days that's what I
said
is it limited accessibility
yes limited accessibility once the
subscription is uh over or it's complete
uh you won't be able to access the
coursework but the link to the session
videos remains accessible forever
the life meant to guided session videos
but because the portal follows a
subscription model that's why uh you
won't be able to access the start
lessons on the portal once the
subscription time period is complete
set start lessons I am referring to
I hope that answers your question
if the participants have any further
queries please let us know in the chat
or you can unmute yourself and let us
know
foreign
how will this program be useful for
plant scientists
that's an interesting question
so plant scientists also have a lot of
data that is coming up from Agriculture
and it requires to be analyzed right so
learning the specific computation
language would definitely be helpful to
analyze data that comes from uh
different agricultural
types Dr Raga would you like to add to
it
yeah I mean for example Babar you have
to perform some Downstream analysis of
this data
so this data is mostly intended to
whoever who can perform uh data analysis
on a structured data so since we are
going to most of the suction data almost
all of the structure data we are going
to deal with is going to come from
biomedical resources so any data that
you can think of like transcriptomics
data like mutation data right like
metagenomics data like metabolomics data
right like drug response data so any
data even image data if you can convert
the image data into their respective
numerical encoded numerical encoder
features so all of this you can use this
use this data to perform downship
analysis what analysis is going to give
you what kind of result we will deal
with these questions with examples if
your data is going to align with some of
the data that we have actually discussed
then you can perform those analysis any
analysis can actually be performed on in
tabular data or structured data but what
we are going to deal with is what to
choose at which question right not all
the time we are going to use principle
component analysis sometimes we are
going to use non-linear Transformations
such as principle coordinate analysis or
something like MDS nmds or something
like tsne so we will discuss when to use
this and what why this choice is
Justified and how you can make use of
this knowledge so when you have
understood the logic behind choosing
specific analysis and how to perform
analysis and some of the understanding
and logic behind some parameters and the
values for the parameters that we are
going to set then you can scale up this
course to apply to any kind of data that
you can get your hands on
so that's how you can make use of this
course if you are going to look or if
you if you are interested in how to use
biological data from plant resources and
and do some bioinformatics analysis then
you have to for example first transform
or trans transfer that biological data
into structured data using some of the
variable known methods that are
available for example for uh
um transcript expression quantification
or variant analysis and other forms of
data that is other forms of analysis
that is very well addressed in the other
programs like genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics programs in our Port please
consult that if you still have any
queries we are yeah we are free to uh
free to be approached and reached by
supported by supported by dot bio
bio so give a brief about what kind of
data you have and what kind of data
analysis that you are expecting to be
performed on this data then we will be
able to suggest you more uh yeah more
direct and uh applicable courses and uh
programs okay
thank you Bubba
thank you so much sir so um if the
participants have no further queries we
are good to end today's webinar
all right then thank you everyone for
joining today's webinar and I hope to
see you at the program so have a great
day